oh my God no hey yeah
I want to tell you that tell them
your pum pum fat
which of your five senses is the most
sensitive one
I would have to say hearing that's a
important thing for me when I see if
someone's attractive or not is how they
sound
I'm sorry
that was so cute
image
that's how they said
oh
but it's just what she said I could you
know how I you know how he sounds ooh
sexy to me that's funny but yes very
juvenile okay rate the five out of ten
that no that was in the comments and if
you guys are already enjoying today's
video make sure to leave a like and a
comment it helps us out with that
algorithm show that support but she was
probably talking about the voice I know
I understand everybody knows let's just
keep playing
please come in
can we move past this part
this is one of the most disruptive Parts
I've ever dealt with and you didn't even
fart
here you go all right
[Music]
I like how they all look standing behind
her and they're just like staring at her
backside
you know what's funny
you're staring at her backside but she
farts from there
no you're not getting that one for me I
don't care I'm getting that one for me
do you know what they're first starting
with what sense of smell
[Laughter]
how sensitive are you with snow honestly
I don't have that great of a sense of
smell kind of smells like my brother so
it's a little weird
reminds me of like a thrift shop
a thrift shop
oh that's all burned you know what
remind me of a thrift shop I'm not gonna
lie I've had ladies before stick their
nose in my armpit that shit's hot
this is hot you know when it makes me
think of what oh
am I attracted to this yup that thing be
smelling like onion smoothie
but I like it them pheromones and make
you jump the bones you feel me
give me that steak
Yeah that [ __ ] is what Carlo Valley
said after you then
oh you smell like really good you smell
like mint interesting smells
definitely interesting he cooked at home
you literally don't smell like anything
and that's really weirding me out
seven just because I can't smell
anything from him
um it is what it is I can't be like butt
hurt over um somebody's nasal
preferences you can be 100 100 if
somebody said they didn't want to date
me because I smell like nothing or I
smell bad yeah that's gonna hurt one
that's a new one
that's a what that's a new one yeah
that's a new one that's a new one that's
new it's like if a girl says listen I
just don't love you anymore I don't like
you versus like I feel nothing for you
that one hurts
oh it's so weird are you a touchy person
I would say it depends on the person oh
he's taller okay
oh okay that's like a beard
sorry
he has like really soft skin okay what
are you using he has really soft skin
what are you using uh Asian
[Laughter]
oh my God these are the softest hands I
ever touched we're like What moisture
i'm like [ __ ] uh have you ever heard of
genetics genetics that's what it comes
down to about the first trick Dramatics
yes that's the first trick yeah it's
like what girls like oh my God you have
such a nice booty like what kind of
workout uh [ __ ] I came from my mom's
[ __ ] it runs into family
not the workout the booty okay that's
what it is
the nicest booties you can't earn you
can't earn the nicest people you can
enhance them you can enhance but the
nicest booties you born with yeah that's
that yam Network it's not Maybelline
it's really used that's that yeah
Network yeah it's passed down from
generation to generation you got that
struggle muscle booty butt cheeks yeah
that's why black folks got that struggle
most white booty and black booty feel
different they could be the same size
but white booty it got a little bit of
like a lot of movement a little extra
loosey-goosey to it you know what I'm
saying like it's on vacation but black
booty it kind of is there it's firm but
it's also nice soft but it like it got
that struggle feel you know what I'm
saying like it's got multiple jobs it's
a different
that's a new word God damn you okay
struggle but yeah I think it's different
[ __ ] yeah
struggle butt yeah live your life yeah
yeah that movie's always flexing because
it got to it's got to it walks like this
[Laughter]
what's this hair oh are those dreads oh
that's so cool okay
she went oh are those dreads he looked
after the other guys well
as a man with dreads you must understand
oh yeah yeah there's a difference the
minute you switch the dreads yeah
there's something that happens yeah and
this head he's like she likes [ __ ]
that's what he was like double curly
hair you're starting to all feel the
same there's like nothing out of the
norm
feels like a person I really don't know
what I'm looking for you're getting
eliminated
because there's nothing Bland that's
nothing nothing yes one guy what the
first Asian guy smelling nothing the
second Nation guy feels like nothing
the third one is gonna look like nothing
but you're gonna just eliminate all the
Asian people based offensive [ __ ] what
are you gonna do for taste
okay I'm gonna eliminate two and five
I think she said I smell like a thrift
shop
which was unique I thought the locks
were going to be uh the money maker man
I thought I was in there
he went from yeah
hold me out this [ __ ] damn
hey Anna my name is Justin and uh you
like jazz
I do like jazz
hey I'm David and uh I love your tattoos
it really does sound like a line though
it really does something hey uh I'm
David and um I like your tattoos the
only thing missing is the hand behind
the back hey I'm David and
I like your
tattoosy it does feel like a lie doesn't
it hi I'm Justin and Anna do you wanna
hang out later
oh my God no hey yeah wow she doesn't
give me Vibes excuse me if I was like hi
I'm Hannah how you doing oh you wanna
hang out later you don't know what he
did he did Anna do you wanna oh is that
what he did that's what the purpose of
that thing the pause was weird it was
because he put Anna in one a date later
that's what that's that's what got me
pissed off hi I'm Justin and Anna do you
wanna hang out later
that's what got me pissed off Anna do
you wanna that's that's cause he
Yeah question mark hey Anna my name is
Josh and I think that uh that hair color
really Suits You
accent yeah crap okay
ding ding
full time she's been like sniffing him
touching him nothing uh accent excuse me
I just wanted to let you know that the
hair
sparkling oh [ __ ] where are you from
well not the touch nothing accent
I want to tell you that tell them
your pum pum fat oh my God where you're
from
I'm gonna eliminate
David
Titus and Justin number two
Australia versus jazz version yeah
everyone else was better no
maybe I didn't sound as confident as
everyone else yeah I think maybe drop
the Wendy Williams voice and you might
have good for drag races but everything
else no I said but you
should not talking about yeah damn you
know exactly what I'm talking about you
know I was a little surprised because I
thought I thought I gave a good line it
really does sound like a line though it
really does something I told you
oh my God
all right ready read
two one
okay
[Music]
you know what this made me think of
what was that video we watched with the
the version who tries to kiss a whole
bunch of women TLC
it's exactly I can watch it
[Laughter]
look at his face look at the face look
at his face look at his face
I think he knows he [ __ ] it up at
least he's aware
[Music]
he was like shaking a lot
and we missed lips the first time
it was cute though
um it felt like a lot more natural and
comfortable I guess
he's like oh my God she's gonna realize
I'm Asian yeah
I want to look at my face when I'm done
accent out the [ __ ] way you fine bro
the world's not the same as it used to
[Music]
hi hi I'm Josh nice to meet you Anna
foreign
on a night out with my boys
I can't even do an Australia
well that was uh that was my first kiss
so
he's a Mormon
you know what gave me like virgin vibes
from this dude nice everything do you
like jazz like that yeah and he didn't
say it like joking he was dead as
serious I watched this way it must be
first yeah and also pointing at someone
like that when they're blindfolded
[Laughter]
it's just like Ryan Secrets trying to
high five a blind dude like come on now
I will say this you know I I respect
people who take chances like this like
you know maybe it was in the show you
want to come out a little bit good for
you for taking that chance even if it
was on camera and you look crazy awkward
I think it's dope you're about to say
stupid
but that's why he was so nervous
oh my God
really
oh that was like really sweet now she
wants to breastfeed him
and he wants to heal like it
she's like
Don't Mind If I Do
let me put some jazz music
how was it for her first kiss
I mean I don't have any of the first
kisses to base it on but from what I can
tell it was pretty good so
it'll be on the internet forever now
all right thanks guys you really look
like a bad porn I promise I'll leave all
these dude in there it looks like a bad
prawn bro this is the set that a lot of
Roads was off yeah
but on a side note I bet you there's a
bunch of women who messaged Josh in the
DMS after definitely yeah yeah at his
height that's the way he looks that's
what she feels like do you want your
second kiss yeah that's why that's why I
said the breastfeeding comment yeah they
like that yeah he definitely sucking on
someone's titties I mean it's cool it's
cool man I had a good time that's fun
yeah that's fun you gotta give me that
one minus the farts at the beginning I
think we all had that was all this my
bad
anyways let us know what you guys think
in the comments below did you guys
enjoyed today's video what did you guys
think let us know